هذا المنزل يعود لعائله ابو علبه قامت
طائرات الاحتلال باستهدافه بشكل مباشر دون
سابق انذار وهو ماهول بالسكان
ايضا حجم الدمار كبير جدا هنا في هذه
المنطقه نتيجه هذا
القصف طبعا كما نشاهد هنا الدمار طال جميع
المنازل المجاوره هنا في هذه المنطقه نحن
الان نتواجد في منزل عائله ابو علبه الذي
قصفه الاحتلال ليله امس وهو مقتض بالسكان
وهول بالاطفال وبنسا كما نشاهد هنا عدد
كبير من الجثامين هنا على الارض في داخل
هذا المنزل نتيجه القصف هنا لهذه العائله
هنا كان نازحين في داخل هذا المنزل كما
نشاهد هنا الاطفال على الارض هذول اللي
بيقولوا عنهم الارهاب هذول طبعا صحيح هذول
اللي بيقولوا عنهم الارهاب ما فيش اهداف
بس علينا الاهداف احنا على المدنيين اللي
صار احنا امنين ما سمعنا الا شيء بينزل
علينا بدون اي سابق انذار امنين نايمين كل
هيتنا 83 نفر 22 رجل و83 امراه موجودين في
في البيت تم اعتقالنا من الصفطاوي اسبوع
الماضي يوم الجمعه زي اللي فات تم
اعتقالنا رحلوا النسوان على جباليا وانتم
الشباب اخذونا واعتقلوا ل يا زكيم وبعدها
رحلو جابونا بالليل خلونا طلعونا
بالبكسرات وجابو نا وقالوا لنا هنا في
الشحن انزلوا على دواز الصفطاوي وتعالوا
على جباليا وجينا هنا على جباليا نازحين
هم اللي قالوا لنا مش احنا يا راج اللي
جابو لنا هنا بدون اي حاجه هي اخوي وابنه
هنا اختي ه اختها وابنها موجودين كل
العيله تبعته امي وابوي وكل هيته موجودين
اولاد خالي هنا عننا ثلاث عيل ما زالت
محاولات اشال الشهداء ابراهيم اطلع يا
راجل ولد مالوش ولا في تنظيمات ولا له في
حدا اطلع اطلع ابراهيم الله
يرحمه نحاول الان الانتقال الى المكان
الاخر في هذا
المنزل هناك ايضا عدد من الشهداء في هذا
المنزل في الجانب الاخر
سنحاول الوصول يعني رغم خطوره
المكان
هنا
ايضا كما نشاهد قدم احد الشهداء في هذا
المكان اشلاء لا احد يستطيع
انتشاله هنا ايضا في الطابق الاخر يوجد
عدد من الشهداء عدد كبير الشهداء هنا في
كل مكان في جميع الطوابق يوجد
شهداء يا الله
[موسيقى]
لم ينجو احد من هذه المجزره لم ينجو احد
من هذا البيت نتيجه هذا
القصف من قبل طائرات
الاحتلال تحت الركام هنا مازال عدد
كبير من
المواطنين انس الشريف الجزيره شمال
غزه